gentlemen I really want to say
congratulations and also uh thank you
for making a kick-ass two-hour uh
Bonanza that you know I was at the
premiere last night what is it like for
the two of you because you put your
heart and soul into this and to hear the
audience reacting to some of the scenes
where like there's blood and guts and
you hear hundreds of people freaking out
what what is that like it's just like
everybody feel like we're back in Roman
times but you're like you're like oh man
yeah
people farting and screaming and
cheering well you know I was talking
about that this morning and I think that
the justification for that is like they
tell myself is that we that what that
proves is I think that we did a decent
job of setting up
that moment so that when the payoff
comes there's a cathartic release from
the audience so they they feel free to
cheer and you know get excited because
of the stakes that we set before that so
it's not just you know cheering for the
sake of violence it's it's Justice in
that moment and so I think we did a
pretty good job I think the audience
spoke pretty clearly last night about
the setup in Paris that's the first time
I'd seen the film with an audience and
it's it's interesting it's hard to get
and you try your best you know Sam sits
in the edit room for a month 12 months
and I get sent edits and then I'll watch
them at home on TV or laptop and give
notes and so on and then the seed all
come together on the big screen with a
big crowd is the real measuring stick
you know that that's where you get a
real
um the instant gratification instant
feedback you understand what plays and
we were talking about this before just
going man that was wild that response
and you know even having done a lot of
the Marvel films it felt like the same
crowd enthusiasm satisfaction edge of
your seed fun
um it was it was very very cool yeah
when a person or two gets killed in the
movie the girls to the left of me were
they were freaking out they were so
excited when someone got killed I'm not
going to say why but um they wanted
Revenge they were yeah you know what I
mean yeah yeah so I went a completely
different uh not on extraction uh if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before any of your projects what is
the thing you'd like them watching and
why and for you if someone has never
seen any of the stunts you were involved
with or stunts you've directed any of
that stuff not the extraction movies
what is the one that you would what's
the one you're really proud of that you
want to sort of point out so I can't
choose from the extraction Universe no I
want to keep to other things but we're
going to come back okay all right he
asked you first did you mean a film that
I have done that I was yeah previous
project that if someone has never seen
anything you've done that you've left
them watching don't watch
um
what's my least favorite film so a home
and away or Dancing with the Stars I'm
hoping away with the soap opera I did in
Australia give you a real feel of the
extent or the limitations uh of me as an
artist I'm gonna go the other way and go
with something that like kind of towards
the peak of my like uh stunt career
probably Captain America Civil War I
think there's so many things in that
that came from conception to completion
that like I would pitch in the room and
then we'd go out and do it and that was
kind of and I'd done other big stunt
coordinating jobs before but that was
the biggest and to have the trust of you
know marvel and the Russo Brothers to
let you know let me Pitch ideas in the
room and then go out and execute him
that that was I was pretty proud of that
one of the things that I really enjoy
about your work Chris is that you're
willing to take a punch on screen you're
willing to get like [__] up and you
know still stand up and go for it there
are some action stars that do not do
that that are do not take the punches
um what is your motivation for being one
of those people that is willing to you
know yeah
um and again we talked about this a lot
it kind of bugs me when I see if you
know people in an action film chaotic
action you know 10 minute sequence
fighting there
still sort of you know nose breathing
and imposing at the end of it I'm like
I don't feel any Jeopardy there you know
if
if I'm not concerned is in me on camera
and I'm not you know
Going Through Hell
I think it's hard for the audience to
empathize with that or understand that
the stakes are high you know and I
understand the kind of wanting to
present to a you know movie star strong
sort of image but I enjoy the the
exhaustion the grip the the pain being
registered and sweat the blood all of it
dirtying it up I think
um gives it a far more integrity and
truth and I think it allows an audience
to
be on the edge of their seat because
they they see what you're going through
as opposed to looking at something
that's kind of pretty and you know
proper and doing some photos I would say
he's the Perfect Blend of Jackie Chan
and uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
because you got the Chan that always had
people on screen better than him and he
always got beat up and then in a very
entertaining way and not afraid to take
a punch but then you had like standing
on a train with a minigun looking like a
total you know badass from the 1980s
action movies it's like the perfect
blend that this guy brings to the to the
screen I think the first film was a
massive hit for Netflix this is going to
be a massive hit for Netflix I know it
is this is a hundred percent
um I know that they're immediately gonna
ask what about another one and I know
you're still presenting this but how
much are you because it's a huge time
commitment to make these movies yeah how
much are you guys already thinking about
well because it's also a ton of work for
you on screen have you guys had the
conversations are you sort of like we're
gonna take a year or two we've had some
conversations but yeah we I mean even
back in the first film when we thought
the character was you know done and
dusted but that's how the original
script was and he died there was no plan
to do a sequel we were just creatively
for the fundament sitting around going
oh imagine if you did this and imagine
fought this character from that movie
and just the the the the fun of it all
and the exploration to see where these
garages could go so um and even we don't
know if there's a third film we hope we
you know if people respond to it we'd
love to make another one
um and again that will be that would be
the same thing you know get me in a room
with with Joe Russo Sam producers
um and the collaboration about what can
we do now that's unexpected how can we
pivot in some way and then totally maybe
have a little adjustment so it doesn't
feel redundant or repetitive I
definitely am almost out of time I'm
gonna have to ask could I have you later
today for a long time we're doing a
screening
um I definitely want to ask you I've
recently spoken to Lorenzo about the
Transformers franchise and Transformers
one and I spoke to Scarlett yesterday
you voice Optimus before Optimus you
know um what was your reasoning for
signing on for Transformers one uh and
what was your take when you saw some of
the animation from ilm because Lorenzo
tells me and Scarlett even said it looks
incredible yeah uh it it does it looks
incredible
um I love the script uh I was one where
I was not sure I hadn't done an
animation before and then I mentioned to
my kids and they went oh yeah that's
awesome
um and so it's it's been really fun
putting down some of the dialogue and
and waving it in with the you know early
days of the animation
um
it's cool it's exciting it's it's you
know Optimus Prime come on
come on and I don't know if you're
allowed to but are you doing it with
your accent no I'll do it um I mean I I
it's we talked about this the Optimus
Prime that you you know that you hear on
the screen
um in the films
is an older mature you know who's been
around for many many many many years
um this is the sort of origin story so
it's the younger verse of him and um so
there's sort of hints and and colorings
that hopefully uh resonate enough with
the Optimus Prime we know but it is a
youthful uh version of him and different
but he won't be Australian right
now the ilm hasn't done an animated
movie since Rango and Rango is
incredible so because ilm is doing it
I'm looking over the moon why because
he's voicing afterwards
100 listen I'm all in on this my last
thing for the two of you there are some
shots in this movie that are like truly
unbelievable like I'm so blown away by
what you did and I'm curious when when
people are watching this what is the
shot or sequence maybe it's the whole 21
minute prison thing that you really just
want to point out and say it shot here
or this thing was such a huge pain in
the ass and here's why the trying I'd
say that the work on the train which is
so many variables it was it was snowing
trains moving at 50 miles an hour uh I'm
on top of the trains helicopter 20 feet
in front of me flying backwards
um helicopters you know landing on
trains six guys jumping out climbing
down the side of the train into the
cabin into a fight sequence that was the
most complicated I think for me and
equally as terrifying as it was
exhilarating and exciting
um and I think you know by the time it
gets that sequence people are kind of
blown away as as we were yeah
I would say challenge I don't know about
pain in the ass I mean all every movie
every sequence has its challenges I
think that but the great part about this
is because it was in Cameron because
you're working with such great people
yeah at the time it might feel like a
pain in the ass meaning it's difficult
and you're pushing yourself and you're
uncomfortable but that means you're
growing and you're doing things that we
hadn't done before and you're pushing
yourself and then you know you get to
see the audience reaction you know a
year later after you do it and you go
well that's why we did that sequence you
know what I mean so it's all worth it in
the end is as difficult as that stuff
was I think that was a real growth
process for me as a filmmaker and
hopefully for him as an actor yeah I
don't know how you're going to Top This
in all seriousness I don't either but
you know we saw that last time too it's
true that is true a little bit of fear
it's a good motivator it is it's good
Room to Grow
I wasn't sure great seeing you both
thank you